PROFESSOR: All right.
So today we resume
efficient origami design.
And we had our guest
lecture from Jason Ku
which was definitely a
different style of lecture.
More survey, lots of
different artwork.
And it had some practical
hands-on experience
with TreeMaker, which
you're welcome to do
more of on your problem set.
And so there weren't
a lot of questions
because this is not a
very technical lecture,
so I thought I'd
show you some more
examples of artistic origami,
things not covered by Jason,
and some other different
types of origami.
So we start with a
bunch of models by Jason
because he didn't
show his own models,
so I thought it'd be fun.
We've seen a bunch
already in this class,
but this is a really nice
F16 that he designed.
And these are all done with
Tree method of origami design.
Another lobster.
We saw a Robert
Lang's lobster before.
This one's different.
This is a version of
the crab that he showed.
So the one you saw was like the
very preliminary, very rough
folding.
But with some
refinement, especially
in the shaping stage,
it looks pretty nice.
Even on the back side you
get some nice features.
We have a little rabbit.
This is kind of in
the traditional style
that he showed where you've
got sharp crease lines that
really define the form.
I assume that's what
he was going for here.
This is a non-tree
method design.
This is using what's
called box pleating.
We've heard about box pleating.
And it means you have
horizontal, vertical,
and 45 degree diagonal folds.
But you can use it just
to shape box-like shapes.
It originally was used by
Moser to make a train out
of one rectangle of paper.
But here we've got a pretty
nice sports car convertible,
even with a color reversal.
So it's pretty cool.
This is one of my favorite
designs of Jason's.
Bicycle, one square
paper, color reversal.
Really thin features.
Probably lots of layers up
there, but pretty awesome.
This is using tree method.
Obviously, the paper is
not connected with a hole
there, so there's
some part here that's
attached just by
folding to another part.
Yeah, questions?
AUDIENCE: How big is that?
PROFESSOR: I'm
trying to remember.
I think the bicycle's
about that big.
Anyone remember?
It's been a while.
So presuming he started
from a piece of paper
maybe twice the size or so.
Looks big here.
And this is a really complicated
butterfly, very exact features,
very cool.
These are all from his website
if you want to check out that.
I'm just giving a selection.
Some of them have
crease patterns
and you can very clearly
see the different parts
of the model, and the
rivers, and so on.
Others do not.
This is one of-- we're
going back in time, so this
is when Jason was just starting
at MIT as an undergrad,
I believe.
This is the dog of someone who
works at the admissions office.
It's very cool.
And this is one of his
earliest models, 2004.
I think it's pretty
elegant on the ice
skate with color reversal.
So that was Jason, for fun.
One question we had
is what about origami
from other materials,
not just paper?
And we've seen a few
examples of that,
but I thought it'd
be a fun theme.
And we'll come back to
this a couple times today.
This is-- I don't if you
call dollar bills paper--
but there is this whole
style of dollar bill origami,
as my t-shirt last
class indicated.
And this is one of the more
famous dollar bill folders.
And he has hundreds and
hundreds of designs.
One of his latest is the alien
face hugger for Prometheus
and so on.
So there's a ton of stuff done.
There's the
particular proportion
of the rectangle
of a dollar bill.
And it's also just
plentily available.
The US is one of the
cheapest currencies
to do bill folding because it
has one of the lowest value
bills.
So there's that.
These are all folded
from toilet paper rolls,
so moving up to cardboard.
This definitely is pretty
different in the way
it acts relative
to standard paper.
And there's this guy who
makes these incredible masks.
Very impressive.
And I'm guessing crayon or
some kind of rubbed color.
So that's pretty awesome.
Here's something
called Hydro-Fold.
This just came out this year
by this guy Christophe Guberan,
where he's got an
inkjet printer.
He's filled it with a
particular kind of ink
that he custom makes.
And as it comes out of the
printer, it folds itself.
It's been printed on both sides.
So one side you get mountains,
the other side you get also
mountains, but relative
to that, it's valleys.
So there's some
fun thing happening
as the liquid dries out that
causes the paper to curve.
You can't get 180
degree folds, but you
can get some pretty
nice creases.
I don't know exactly how
much accelerated that is,
but he's hopefully
visiting MIT later on
and we'll find out more.
So it's using regular paper,
but a different folding style,
a different material
for folding.
You can also take casts
of existing paper models.
So Robert Lang has
done a bunch of these
with a guy named Kevin Box
where they take a paper model
and cast or partially cast it.
In this case, in bronze.
In these cases, stainless steel.
So these are two.
This is like traditional
origami crane and Robert Lang
complex crane.
And for fun, the crease pattern
for those two looks like this.
And this is I think mostly
on a 22.5 degree grid system.
May actually be--
you can see here
there's a river
that's not orthogonal.
So it's not intended
to be box pleated.
So that gives you
these 22.5 degrees.
There's some other features
out here, but the most of it
is this 22.5 degree system.
So as you might guess
from now, there's
some questions about this.
You don't necessarily
entirely use the tree method.
You use a mix of
different things.
In particular,
there's a technique
called grafting where you
can combine two models.
If you're interested
in that, check out
Origami Design Secrets.
And for things like
the dragon where
you have this textured
pattern-- which we'll get to,
it's called a
tessellation-- and you
want to combine that with
doing tree method stuff,
you can do that.
But it's not necessarily
mathematical formal
how to do that.
It's just people figure
it out by trial and error.
There's probably
interesting open problems
there, haven't been formalized.
Here's another cardboard design.
This is by our friend
Tomohiro Tachi.
That's him.
So this was initially a bed.
And you fold it up.
And you need a
pillow, of course.
It turns into a chair.
So that's pretty awesome.
So that's one of
the great things
about using non-paper is you get
a lot more structural integrity
and support.
And that leads us
into steel, which
also makes for stronger models.
And this is another
design by Tomohiro.
We made it here at MIT using
a waterjet cutter in CSAIL.
And it makes a
pretty nice table.
This is based on a curve crease
design which initially drafted
on paper, and then in plastic.
And then when it seemed
to be working pretty well,
we waterjet cut this steel
and these perforation lines.
And then many hours of painful
bending or difficult bending
later, some hamming
and so on, we
got it to fold into
a pretty nice shape.
So that's one example.
I have another example.
This is out of
much thinner steel.
And this happens to be laser
cut using a newer laser
cutter in the Center for Bits
and Atoms in the Media Lab
building.
So a little bit of a cheat.
This is not from a square paper.
It's been cut a
little bit smaller.
I need chalk.
Jason.
So take a square of paper.
You can cut out-- these
are 22.5 degree angles.
You can cut out material
like this from your square
and still make a good crane.
But it substantially
reduces the number
of layers you get,
especially at the corners.
And so we exploited that because
this is pretty thick material.
And this is just the Center
for Bits and Atoms logo.
But pretty cool.
You can make a crane.
And we added these
crease lines to get
the nice bow of the crane.
So pretty nice.
This is made by Kenny Cheung
who just graduated, PhD.
So that was some metal.
Next topic is tessellations.
So this is a particular
style of origami.
It goes back-- probably
the earliest tessellation
folder is Ron Resch.
The early history's a little
hard to know for sure.
Ron Resch was an artist
starting in the '60s.
He died just a few years ago.
We've met him.
Pretty crazy guy.
Did a lot of cool origami
foldings early in the day.
There's a patent that describes
this particular folding.
And what makes a
tessellation is essentially
a repeated pattern of some sort.
It could be periodic.
It could be aperiodic.
You've probably heard
of tessellations
like the square grid or some
kind of mesh of two dimensions.
Origami tessellations
are in some sense
trying to represent
such a tessellation.
Here you've got the
triangular grid,
if you look closely,
after folding.
But also if you look at
the crease pattern itself,
it is a tessellation.
It's going to be a repeated
pattern of polygons.
So you've got sort of two
levels of tessellation going on.
It's like a double
rainbow or something.
And so there are lots
of examples of this.
Here's some kind of traditional
flat origami tessellations.
Some of these are more
traditional than others.
You've some very simple--
well not simple, but beautiful
repeating patterns.
Octagons and squares here.
You can count them.
And this is still periodic.
Then we get to some
less periodic stuff.
And so there are
techniques for designing
these kinds of tessellation.
If you start with a
regular 2D tessellation,
there's a transformation
from that tessellation
into a crease pattern, which
then makes things like this.
You can see here there's
sort of clear edges here.
And that represents the
tessellation it's based on.
It's just been kind of
shrunk a little bit.
Each of these is a pleat.
There's a mountain
and a valley crease.
And so on all of these,
I believe, that style.
You've got essentially a twist
fold at each of the vertices.
And you've got a pleat
along each of the edges.
And if you want to
play with these,
there's software called Tess
freely available online.
And I'll show it to you.
And it lets you design
things like this,
following a
particular algorithm.
So you start with some geometry.
And I don't really
know these by heart.
So it has a fixed
set of geometries
that you can play with.
We'll try this one.
And you get a regular 2D
tessellation of polygons.
And then you increase the--
then I hit, Show Creases.
And it's applying a
particular algorithm
which is essentially-- it's
maybe more dramatic if I
increase this value or
change it dynamically.
It's rotating each of the
polygons, so a twisting.
Sorry, that's negative.
As it rotates them, you
get-- let me know you.
It'd be nice if this is
color-coded, but it's not.
So these two squares
are two original squares
of the tessellation.
They've been twisted.
And then these edges
which used to be--
so they're shrunk and twisted.
And then these edges
used to be attached.
We're now going to put in a
little parallelogram there.
And you just do that everywhere.
And this is a crease pattern.
It will fold flat.
Doesn't work for
all tessellation.
And there's a paper
characterizing
which tessellations
it works for.
They're called spider webs.
But it's a very simple
algorithm and it's
led to tons of tessellations
over the years.
And you can export this to
PDF, print it out, and fold it.
It obviously takes
a little while.
One of the fun surprises
of this algorithm, which
this is made by Alex
Bateman and this
was just sort of a
surprise by accident.
I think there's a slider at the
top, the pleat angle slider.
And by accident, he didn't
require it to be positive.
And he realized that if you
made it negative-- whoa, that's
a little too negative-- you
actually get the folded state.
This is what that
crease pattern will
look like after you fold it
flat, because it's essentially
reflecting across each crease.
So this is with all
the layers stacked up.
So you get sort
of an x-ray view.
But it gives you
a sense of-- it's
hard to see the thickness
here so we actually wrote
a little thing here which
is a little bit slow--
we'll see if it works--
called Light Pattern.
And it's just measuring how
many layers are stacked up
at each point and
it will hopefully
give you a shaded pattern
so that if you held it up
to light where the dark
spot's going to be,
where the bright
spot's going to be.
So the idea is this
will help you figure out
whether something's going to be
interesting or not interesting
ahead of have time.
Then you can go fold once you've
set the parameters exactly
like you like.
I've just shown one of
the parameters there.
There's another
one, pleat ratio.
So this is cool.
I think an interesting project
would be to extend this tool.
It's open source.
Lots of interesting
things to do with it.
Add more tessellations.
Improve the interface.
Maybe try to show 3D
visualization as it folds.
There are existing
3D origami tools
which we'll see in the very
next lecture, Rigid Origami
Simulator, that might make
that not too hard actually.
It'd be cool to try.
Put it on the web I think
would be interesting.
Point it to JavaScript
or something.
Because I think there's
really cool tessellation here.
Not many people have
actually used the software
because it's a little
awkward and as you can see,
Light pattern
doesn't always work.
But I think that's just
because this tessellation's
a little too big.
All right.
So that was Tess.
And that style of tessellation.
You can see that you could
some really cool thing.
This is what a light
pattern looks like.
So you get the different
shades of gray.
50 shades of gray?
Then there are more three
dimensional tessellations.
So this is in a different style.
And this is folding
a very simple origami
base called water bomb.
And the resulting
thing is not flat,
but it's very simple
crease pattern
and pretty cool three
dimensional result.
This is not captured by Tess.
And that would be a
different style project
to generalize to
3D tessellations.
That'd be very cool.
Here's that same tessellation,
I think, or a very similar one,
but made out of stainless steel.
So you can see
there's big cuts here.
So this is probably made
on a waterjet cutter.
And then you leave little tabs.
So you wear gloves so you
can fold this by hand.
Probably not easy, but possible.
Here's some more back to paper,
some more 3D tessellations.
And if you're interested in
playing with tessellations,
you could try Tess.
Or there's this really
good book came out recently
by Eric Gjerde,
Origami Tessellations.
And this is actually
one of the models
that's described in here.
Unlike traditional origami,
there's no sequence of steps.
All of these are based on
here's a crease pattern,
fold along all the
lines, and then
collapse all the
lines simultaneously.
Like a lot of mathematical
origami design,
but there's great stuff in here.
Really cool
tessellations and some
of the best photographs
of tessellations.
So definitely
check out that book
if you want to do tessellations.
This is the crease pattern.
Give you an idea for this guy.
It's also periodic.
This is triangular twists.
You can kind of recognize
that, but it's very cool.
More alternate materials.
This is polypropylene.
And there's this
great Flickr site,
polyscene by Polly Verity.
And tons of examples of
foldings by polypropylene.
So it's a kind of plastic.
It gets scored by a machine
and then folded by hand.
And so really striking results.
You get this nice
semi-transparency.
It works really well
with tessellations.
Here's some recent ones we
just found making things out
of mirror and plywood and copper
as like the surface material,
and then polyester and fabric,
or polyester and Tyvek.
Tyvek is like those
envelopes, plasticy envelopes
that you can't really
stretch or tear.
Really great stuff.
And you can buy it in sheets.
So that's sort of
the base layer that's
holding everything together.
At the creases here, you can see
through to the fabric material.
And then this is
plywood on the surface.
So these are all
different tessellations,
kind of tessellations.
These have been wrapped
around to make vessels
or to make-- they call
it a shoulder cape.
Looks like a set of armor.
But really cool stuff when
you work with other materials.
It'd be a great project
in this class, I think,
to try some of these techniques.
Combining some basic
foldable sheet material
with some richer
material, you can
make some really cool stuff.
Once you have a
computer model of it,
you can-- and we'll
see in the next lecture
different computer tools for
doing that-- then actually
building them I think
is really striking.
Back to paper, although this
barely looks like paper.
These are some really cool
kind of traditional style
tessellations, but folded in a
very unusual and beautiful way
by Joel Cooper who's one
of the leading tessellation
folders in a certain sense.
He's best known for
tessellations like this,
however.
So these are all based
on a regular triangular
grid, but not quite identical.
It's definitely
not periodic here.
Going for human forms.
He has whole busts and heads.
And these are really striking.
They're not designed
particularly algorithmically.
My understanding is he
comes up with little gadgets
for certain features
like cheeks and so on,
and he starts composing them
in ways that seem to work.
And he has a collection
of different pieces
that work together well.
And he can get really
intricate, really beautiful
3D surfaces out of that.
So this is kind of begging
to be studied mathematically
in some way, but
pretty challenging.
This is an interesting
tessellation style
by Goran Konjevod.
He was a co-author on the
"Folding a Better Checkerboard"
paper that I talked about.
And the crease pattern
here is extremely boring.
It's a square grid.
But the mountain
valley assignment
is not quite trivial.
And because of the
thickness of the material,
it actually gets this
curving behavior.
So this thing is technically,
mathematically it's flat.
It's like this really
boring pleated square.
But the way it goes is
you sort of take a square
and you pleat the edge and
then you pleat the edge
and you pleat the edge.
So you do mountain
valley, mountain valley.
And here you're alternating
between this side and this side
and this side and this side.
And that gives you
this kind of corner.
But because the material
is nonzero thickness,
you get these
really cool curves.
And when you change which
order you fold the pleats in,
you can really control
a lot of this surface.
It's kind of magical.
He has a bunch of
designs like this.
You can check out his images on
the web if you want to see more
and diagrams.
And I think this is our
last tessellation example.
So here, goal is
to make US flag.
And there's a video
of this being made,
but it's just fold along
the lines and then collapse.
You're using a
tessellation element
to get the stars in the flag.
And this is what the
crease pattern looks like.
So you've got a
nice tessellation
here and then sort of a
simpler tessellation out here,
which is just some pleats.
And getting those pleats
to resolve to the outside.
This is by Robert Lang.
Very cool.
So next, I want to transition
to kind of modular origami
where you use multiple parts.
But before we get there, this
is I guess the oldest recorded
example of a picture of origami.
So this is from 1734.
This is a reference.
This is the actual object-- I
believe, a newspaper article.
And it's a little
rough to see here,
but there's an origami
crane and a bunch
of other classic origami
things like water bomb.
So the assumption is by
1734, origami was well-known.
All the classic
models were out there.
We don't know how
far back it goes.
It could be as
early as when paper
was invented which
was like 50 AD.
Somewhere between 50 and 1734,
origami really hit it big.
That's the big range.
But I wanted to show this
because of the cranes.
And one way to combine
multiple parts together
is to combine multiple
cranes together.
And there's this whole
world, hiden senbazuru,
which is connected cranes.
And orikata means you're
cutting in addition to folding.
So this is a rectangle of paper.
It's been split along
two lines and then folded
into three cranes.
So that's pretty cool.
And there's much
more intricate ones
where you take a square of
paper or a rectangle paper,
do lots of cuts, subdivide your
thing into a bunch of squares.
Each square gets
folded into a crane.
The tips of the cranes stay
connected at these tabs.
And the challenge when
you're folding these
is to not tear at the tabs.
But then you'll get
these really cool folds.
This is an old book from
1797, not much later
than that last reference.
We have a copy of
this book if you're
interested in checking it out.
Lots of different designs.
There have been some recent
works in making really nice.
These are spheres out
of connected cranes
by Linda Tomoko.
And here's one out
of silver foil.
So really cool connected cranes.
So that's a traditional
origami style.
I want to transition
to modular origami
where you combine lots
of identical parts,
but now they're
actually disconnected.
And this is a very simple unit.
I think it's just
water bomb based.
And then they nest
into each other.
You've probably seen these
kind of swans, modular swans.
I think they're a
very old tradition.
Possibly China?
I'm not sure exactly.
So a kind of traditional model.
But you get a lot of
geometric models like this.
So these are examples
of different units.
You take typically
a square of paper.
You do maybe 10 or 20
folds and you get a unit.
And then you combine a bunch
of these units together.
So one of the classic units
is called a Sonobe unit.
Sonobe units use
sort of backwards,
but you can get these
kinds of cool polyhedra.
Robert Neale, he's a magician
and an origami designer.
Has some units.
This one's called
the penultimate unit.
And so you can see each of
these green strips is one unit--
blue strip, pink strip.
There's a lot of units in here.
90 in total.
Typically, one per edge of
the polyhedron, sometimes
two per edge.
And they lock together
in certain ways
to really hold these
nice shapes here.
Tom Hull folds a lot
of modular origami.
And one of his units
is called a PHiZZ unit.
I think it can make
anything as long as you
have three units coming
together at each vertex.
So as long as every
vertex has degree three,
you can kind of make
your polyhedron.
I guess the lengths also
have to be the same or else
you have to adjust the
units to be different.
So each of the units
here is identical,
except different color patterns.
Here's a big example of a
PHiZZ unit construction.
So this is 270 units.
Take a long time to fold
probably and even more time
to weave them together.
Usually putting the last
piece in is the hardest.
Here's some more
examples by Tom Hull.
He has another unit
called the hybrid unit.
And this is what three of
them look like woven together.
So this paper is probably red
on one side, black on the other.
And there's one unit that
comes here, wraps around
the tetrahedron, and two more.
And you combine them
and you can make
all these different
regular solids.
And you get these
spiky tetrahedra
on each of the faces
which is pretty cool.
So this like icosahedra,
a regular 20-sided
die, on the inside here,
but then each of them
has a spike from there.
And here's a big one he made.
This is actually one of
my favorite polyhedra,
the rhombicosidodecahedron.
It's got all the polygons--
squares, triangles, hexagons,
if I recall correctly.
It's obvious, right?
And one of the challenges here
is getting the color patterns
to be nice and
symmetric and even.
And Tom Hull is one of
the experts in that.
He's a mathematician,
but also an origamist.
And then he started
combining the two
because of problems like this.
Next we get to polypolyhedra.
This is the idea of
taking multiple polyhedra
and weaving them
together and then making
that out of origami.
And this is one of the
most famous designs
in this family called FIT, or
Five Intersecting Tetrahedra,
designed by Tom Hull.
This is a photograph of one
that I am the proud owner.
It was folded by
Vanessa Gould, who
directed Between the Folds,
which is the documentary you
all heard about when
Jason mentioned it.
And it's available free
streaming on Netflix,
so you should all watch it.
Or we could have a showing here.
Actually, how many
people are interested?
Haven't seen the movie or
would like to see it again
related to this
class some evening?
OK.
That's maybe enough
to do a showing.
Anyway, she folded this.
Cool.
And then Robert Lang enumerated
all possible polypolyhedra
that are symmetric
in a certain sense.
And these are two examples
that he thought were so cool.
He made them out of paper.
Most of them just exist
as virtual designs.
People have been folding
them, but there's
hundreds if not
thousands in his list.
So if you're
interested, check out
his website on polypolyhedra.
These are, again, modular.
And finally, we come
to modules of cubes.
And this is why you
have business cards.
And I thought we
could play with this.
This is a life-size chair made
from a particular unit, which
is out of business cards,
folding these individual cubes
and then sticking them
together in a particular way.
Unfortunately, the
material's not strong enough
to actually support much weight.
So you can't sit on this
chair, but it looks just
like a real chair.
It's very cool.
You can make any set of cues
you like and interlock them
together.
One of the craziest
experimenters with this cube
module is Jeannine
Mosely, who's a MIT
alum and lives in the area.
And she became really famous for
making this Menger Sponge out
of 66,000 business cards.
It took something like
five years to make this.
She made a lot of
the units herself.
And so this is trying to
represent a particular fractal,
which is pretty cool.
You start by taking a cube
and then drilling holes
through each of the sides
in the center third.
So this is one iteration.
You just drill
through that hole,
that hole, same on each side.
Remove that material.
That leaves you
with-- how many cubes?
Eight cubes on top.
Eight cubes on the bottom.
Four cubes in the
middle, which is 20.
For each of the 20
cubes, you recurse.
So for each of
those 20 cubes, you
drill holes, drill holes
from all the sides.
And after two iterations,
you have this structure.
After three iterations,
After infinitely
many iterations--
well, no, this is not infinite.
But this is actually the same
number of iterations as that.
So in principle, you keep going.
But at any fixed point, you can
treat the smallest little unit
that hasn't been recursed
as one of these cubes,
build that, and then
assemble them together.
It's challenging.
You could not take this--
with the business cards,
you could not go
to the next level--
not because it
would take forever,
but also because it would
collapse under its own weight.
So trade-off there.
That was 66,000 business
cards, five years.
I thought, man, that
was a big project.
But then Jeannine says,
what else can we make?
And she got more volunteers
for these future projects
so they were made a lot faster.
This is a cool fractal.
Not quite as many,
50,000 business cards.
And this is a fractal
that she designed.
Kind of complimentary.
You take a cube and subdivide
it into three by three by three,
and then remove all the corner
cubes, and then recurse.
And she calls it the
Moseley Snowflake
because if you look
at it from the corner,
you get this nice Koch
snowflake outline.
And this is the real
one from the same view.
It's a little big, so it's
hard to see it all in one shot.
And so that's pretty awesome.
And then her most recent project
was 100,000 business cards.
This is I guess the
world record for origami
made from business cards.
And this is a model
of Union Station
in Worcester, Massachusetts.
Hundreds of volunteers
here to make this.
This was done for first night
celebration a year or so ago.
Pretty amazing.
And you can see, you can really
sculpt with these cube units,
do lots of cool stuff.
And there's a few extra
details on the surface there.
So I thought we
would make something.
So these are diagrams
you can start working
or I can tell you
about how they work.
Each cube is made from six
identical business cards.
I have here my
own business cards
from when I first
arrived, old classic.
So you start by taking two
of your business cards.
You have to decide whether
you want the white face up
on your cube and make
it nice and clean
or you want the pattern side up.
Whichever one you
want to expose,
you keep that on the outside
and you bring the two cards
together.
So in this case, I'm going
to make the pattern side out.
And you want to align
these approximately evenly.
You want them as perpendicular
as possible and then
roughly evenly spaced.
And then you just
mountain fold both sides.
So you want mountain folds on
the side that you care about.
And that gives
you a nice square.
Now I've got two nice
squares folded like this.
Repeat three times,
you get six units.
Four and six.
OK, once you've
got the six units,
you want to combine
them together.
This is where it gets fun.
And it's helpful to look
at this diagram down here.
These are some diagrams
by Ned Batchelder.
And so this idea of making
cubes has been around.
I think it was Jeannine's
idea to combine them together.
So this is what one
cube looks like.
Why don't I fold,
make one of them.
Basically, you want the
tabs going on the outside.
And you need to alternate
so they lock together.
between oriented
horizontal and
oriented vertical.
So they recommend starting by
making a corner, three of them
like that, and then
fill around the outside.
And then as usual, putting in
the last piece is the hardest.
So I've got to get--
I want all the tabs
on the outside like that.
And I probably
should've mentioned--
fold the creases really hard.
You can do that to a certain
extent afterwards, make it nice
and cubey.
But in this case, I got
my six-sided cube out
of those six units.
It's got my name
right in the center.
So you can design business card
specifically for this purpose.
I accidentally did.
And that's how
you make one cube.
Once you've got two cubes,
you can lock them together
by just twisting them 90
degrees relative to each other
and just sliding the tabs
in, just sliding the tabs in.
This is also like
doing that last move.
So this tab's got to go in
here between these two tabs.
It wouldn't hold
together very well
if it wasn't hard
to put together.
So once you've got them
together, you've got two cubes.
Now if you want, for
a finishing touch,
you can also make another
unit and cover the surfaces.
So all of Jeannine
Moseley's examples
are done this way where at
the end-- I haven't tried this
lately-- you stick on a business
card just on the surface
so it interlocks here and
then interlocks over here.
Ho boy, this is challenging.
And then you get a full square
business card on the outside.
And you can use this to, if you
have different colored business
cards or you want a nice,
clean white surface, no seams.
So you have these
tabs right now,
but once you add
something like this,
you have a nice seamless
square on the outside.
So you use up more
business cards,
but it can make for
a nicer surface.
So any questions
about making these?
I thought we would make some
and then build something.
But for that, I need
suggestions on what to build.
Oh, an MIT.
I like that.
Let's make an MIT.
So let's design.
So by MIT, do you mean
MIT logo or like an M?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10 cubes.
Easy.
Exploding cubes.
I wonder if you can use
these to make pinatas?
MIT.
We could also just make
a row at the bottom.
One cube higher.
Four more minutes.
AUDIENCE: We could
do Minecraft origami.
AUDIENCE: Ohh.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yes!
AUDIENCE: That's a good idea.
PROFESSOR: Minecraft
is a good source.